- [Voiceover] A tea infuser in the shape
of a right rectangular pyramid is
seven point nine centimeters tall
and has a base three centimeters long
and one point five centimeters wide.
To make the best tea,
the infuser should be 80% filled with tea.
What is the volume of
tea, in cubic centimeters,
needed to fill the infuser
to 80% of its capacity.
Round to the nearest tenth.
All right, so this tea infuser,
it's kind of one of those fancy
teabags that hold their shape.
It's the shape of a right
rectangular pyramid.
So, it's gonna look something like this.
Let's see.
Its base is three centimeters
by one point five centimeters.
So, its base is, let's say
that's three centimeters
by one point five centimeters.
So, it might look something like that.
So that's its base and we draw that.
Actually, I can even label it.
So, this is three centimeters.
This is one point five centimeters
and then it is seven point
nine centimeters tall.
So, if we went from the center
and if we were to go straight up
it's seven point nine centimeters tall.
So, this dimension right over
here is seven point nine,
seven point nine centimeters,
and it's a right rectangular pyramid.
So, you can kind of think
of the pyramids in Egypt
although this one, this one, this one's a
little taller relative
to its base and those
but you might've seen
these fancy tea infusers.
So, it's gonna look something like this
and if it was transparent you would
be able to see this one right back here.
So, what we can do is we can first
find the volume of this
right rectangular pyramid
and then they're gonna,
they say that it should
be 80% filled with tea.
So, we need to figure out
what 80% of its volume is
and then that's gonna
tell us what's the volume
of tea needed to fill the
infuser to 80% of its capacity.
Now, you might be saying,
"How do I figure out the volume
"of a right rectangular pyramid?"
Well, I'm about to tell you that.
And there's a formula.
I'm not gonna prove it here
especially if you're in
the middle of the SATs.
No amount of time for proofs.
But the formula here in some
ways is strangely intuitive.
You multiply, essentially, the base,
the area of the base times the height
and then divide that by three.
And so what's the area of the base?
Well, it's going to be,
it's going to be the
length times the width,
the length times the width
and then you multiply
that times the height.
So, it's gonna be the
length times the width
times the height and
then divide it by three.
So, in this case, it's gonna be,
and just another way of thinking about it,
this right over here, the
length times the width,
that's the area of this base,
and then you multiple it times the height,
and then you divide by three.
If you didn't divide
by three you would get
the volume of the cube, of the cube,
oh, not the cube.
I should say the rectangular prism.
It's not a cube.
All the dimensions are not the same.
That would, that would contain this thing.
But we're not concerned about the
volume of the rectangular prism.
We are concerned with the volume
of the right rectangular pyramid.
And so, this is going to be
a length three centimeters
times a width of one
point five centimeters
times height of seven
point nine centimeters
divided by, divided by three.
Well, this three, three
divided by three's just one,
and let's see.
You have centimeters, whoops, this is.
Just let me change.
This is centimeters right over here.
Divided by three.
That cancels with that.
You have centimeters times
centimeters times centimeters.
It's going to be centimeters cubed.
So, your volume is going to be, let's see.
It's gonna be one point five times
seven point nine centimeters
cubed or cubic centimeters.
Now, that's the volume of the entire,
of the entire fancy, I guess, tea infuser.
I call 'em fancy teabags.
But we wanna know what
80% of its capacity is
because that's how much tea we need.
So, we wanna multiply this times 80%.
So, you would multiple zero point eight
times one point five
times seven point nine
centimeters cubed and let's see,
zero point eight times one point five.
Let's see, that would be
point eight plus point four
so this is, this part, this
is gonna be one point two
times seven point nine centimeters cubed.
We could try to approximate this, in fact,
that this is looking approximately right,
but we could use a calculator here.
So, let's just feel good about it.
So, if we say one point
two times seven point nine
we get nine point four eight.
Nine point four eight
and if we round to the nearest tenth,
well, the round to the nearest tenth
we have an eight in the hundredths place,
we're gonna round up to nine point five,
which is exactly that choice.